hello everybody and welcome back we are
going to proceed with our next
discussion on digital therapeutics so
the field of digital therapeutics is
moving quickly and you know we think of
digital therapeutics as somewhat of a
subset of the whole field of digital
healthcare digital medicine we heard
about some of the other aspect aspects
of it earlier today the use of
artificial intelligence looking at large
data sets the various types of benefits
and cautions that we have about doing
that as well as drug supply drug pricing
etc but but really when it comes down to
it it's a big part of this is about the
the opportunity to change the
therapeutic value proposition for
patients so the field the field of
therapeutics specifically is also
advancing ravel rapidly to recap the
optimism that we have in this forward
the FDA has issued guidance there's been
there's been progress in getting
specific software approved as a
therapeutic landmark decisions just
within the last two years a lot of
promising data is being published in a
variety of different diseases diabetes
oncology behavioral health mental
disease etc but of course it's not easy
and in fact there are many challenges
many difficulties especially many
difficulties that small companies face
going forward and in fact
a lot of small companies have to pivot
around away from their original
objectives of going to consumers and
over half wind up switching to a b2b
business model and not it doesn't affect
just small companies large companies
have famously failed in a variety of
different digital health applications
much with digital healthcare records and
you know the digitizing of personal
records I mean almost every company now
that we see kept getting back into it
like Apple and and Google and Microsoft
have been here before
have failed and now we're coming back
and even some names that we no longer
hear of like healthy on you know one of
the one of the highest profile blow ups
that that's happened in this space so it
kind of raises the question what are
what are factors of success and that's
that's what I'm going to pose as the
theme of the discussion for this panel
today and you know to to you know borrow
the words of Tolstoy every digital
company fails in the same way but the
ones that are successful are successful
in their own special way so let me let
me introduce our speakers and kind of
keeping that in mind about what is the
special thing that made your company
successful so actually let me first go
go down the line and I'll introduce
everybody and then and then we'll come
back to Lena and ask her to speak for a
few minutes so Lynn Hamilton is chief
operating officer of talk space talk
space if you haven't heard of the
company you've probably seen the advert
the ads on television and posters where
they you they they have Michael Phelps
as a spokesman for for behavioral health
and really helping level the player
playing field in terms of access remove
the stigma
and bring therapies forward her
background is actually on the Health
System side and she has a consulting
background before she took the
leadership role at talk space Eddie is
one of us he's a Yale graduate and has a
PhD from Yale he's the founder and CEO
of Akili interactive which is now
engaged in a an fda-approved trial a
pivotal trial using their software for
behavioral health and we'll ask him to
talk about that next name is John John
Wang is a cardiologist who after being a
practicing cardiologist and and running
and cardiovascular clinic went into
business he worked at McKinsey he
whereas worked at a couple of notable
healthcare companies including Amgen and
now he's head of cardiovascular and
metabolic innovation at Johnson &
Johnson and and he's also the the person
who was largely responsible for bringing
Johnson and Johnson and Apple together
to collaborate on the future of clinical
development and we'd love to hear a
little bit more about that and then at
the end
dr. Plowman scooter Plowman he's the
medical director at Proteus digital
health very interesting company that has
puts technology on a pill in order to
help promote patient adherence scooter
is an impressive guy in addition to his
medical degree he attended Oxford he
sports speaks multiple languages any
publishers frequently in this area on
use of digital technologies and and and
also Proteus in particular is it's not
just tech innovative around technology
in medicine but also bringing innovation
to its
and small so we'd like to hear a little
bit more about that so what I'll ask is
that each one of our speakers just talk
for a few minutes about about their
company and what how they see kind of
their them pushing the boundaries
forward of additional medicine and
digital health and then we'll have some
questions and we'll ask the audience to
also have some questions so let's start
with Linton sure good afternoon
everybody so I'll talk a little bit
about talk space which is as was
mentioned an online behavioral health
therapy company and it was really born
out of a recognition of one of the
broken parts of the healthcare system of
which you could argue there are many but
behavioral health in particular where
there is such a high incidence of
occurrence and a low incidence of people
being able to access care and having
lived on the healthcare side of the
equation before I can tell you about the
number of challenges we would hear
directly from people who wanted to
access care and couldn't and they range
anything from I can't find a provider to
I can't go to a recurring appointment
which in behavioral health is one of the
key components to success and so as the
company was being formed we looked at
how do we take that face-to-face
experience and turn it into a digital
modality recognizing that in behavioral
health or actually is no physical
contact that's required also recognizing
that people do feel a sense of stigma
when they're entering into a therapist
office and talking face-to-face with
someone that they don't know chances are
the therapist was somewhat of a random
selection unless they had a referral
from someone and so we started looking
at all these different barriers and how
do we use technology to help solve for
those barriers so how do we profile our
therapists so we know that when a
patient wants to access therapy they
know what their therapist specialty is
they also know what their outcomes are
which is something that was completely
absent in behavioral health because
everything happens in a traditional
sense in a in a verbal and therefore
redacted way so we started recognizing
first that we could help people
find providers second that we could take
the whole appointment piece out of the
equation because therapy doesn't
necessarily have to be a set 50-minute
prescribed set of time and could happen
in a more ongoing way which may even be
more beneficial than bucketing
everything till your next 2-week
appointment and also helping to erase
the stigma piece of it if I'm behind my
screen and I'm sending messages to my
therapist she can't necessarily see how
I'm feeling when I'm sending it and it
really kind of helps take that stigma
effect away from it we mentioned the
promotions that we're doing with Michael
Phelps and it was really around that it
was around stigma and you know if
Michael Phelps one of the arguably
greatest Olympians at least in our time
could mention his battles with
depression and mental health then it
kind of puts him on a level playing
field that a lot of people struggle with
mental health and it's okay to get help
so that's a long-winded way of talking
about talk space and how we were founded
and we have a lot of ground we plan to
cover going forward including psychiatry
as well as working with primary care
doctors but and you know just to mention
you know talk space has really been
terrific about pushing forward the the
ability to provide access to to mental
health and you know to harness the the
recognition of somebody like like
Michael Phelps that's just the suits the
top layer
they have conferences where where they
bring together leaders in in healthcare
and practitioners in healthcare they've
had a number of efforts to
give away some of their services
particularly around teenagers mode most
recently and you know it it kind of
fascinates me the ability to both
innovate on the technology as well as
the business model to make these things
work so alright Eddie could sure happy
to hi everybody
so again Eddie Martucci I'm one of the
co-founders in the CEO of Achille
Interactive we're a proscription digital
therapeutic company and what that means
is that we're making software that we
believe can and should be the medicine
for certain patients and certain
symptoms of disorders and can be
prescribed and so we founded the company
back at the end of 2011 with actually a
very similar need premise that Lynn was
talking about where we're we're seeing
across mental health and neurology and
behavioral health that some of the same
problems that exist today essentially
have existed for decades where the main
modality that's scalable to treat these
conditions and we're talking about
everything from depression to pediatric
behavioral disorders anxiety etc are
medications and medications in many
cases are either not fully effective or
have side-effects and at the very least
are very poorly targeted for certain
types of neurology and the only other
option existing at that point is as we
talked about behavioral intervention
with therapists which is not very
scalable unless you innovate and so we
actually ended up in a slightly
different place we were really got
excited and and almost obsessed with the
idea that one of the big needs that we
saw in medicine for the future is
cognitive function or in many disorders
cognitive dysfunction it's an area that
is generally very poorly targeted by
molecular methods
mainly because cognition works at the
functional circuit level not necessarily
or we at least don't necessarily
understand enough about the receptor
based pharmacology of how that works
and so across many of these disorders
that I'm mentioning one of the most
prevalent issues one of the biggest
issues that is actually long-term
determinants of quality of life
employment status etc is actually
cognitive dysfunction so it's the types
of symptoms that people sometimes don't
recognize as readily until their
debilitating so we've actually brought
forward software products that we've
developed to be prescription software to
directly treat cognitive dysfunction in
a very safe way I've kind of avoided in
that last minute and a half or two
minutes I guess one of our claim to fame
czar what people like to like to point
to us for we deliver our algorithms our
sensory stimulus to activate cognitive
networks in action video games and so
our delivery vehicle what patients have
in their hands are actually fun active
video games and one of our core
philosophies is we hope that with
digital therapeutics broadly and
certainly with how we approach this
industry that we can go beyond just
treating a disorder in a new way we can
go beyond prescription treatments for a
range of disorders to complement drugs
we can actually help patients rethink
medicine in a new way so we're very
excited and we think there's a huge
opportunity for when a patient is taking
their medicine if you put medicine it's
not in quotes it really is medicine
it just happens to not look like a pill
patients can actually not just tolerate
their medicine but maybe enjoy their
medicine maybe be delighted by the
experience of medicine and those are
phrases we tend to not hear together but
are very very close to our heart so
where we are today we're also a bit
recognized for being a company that's
raised a lot of money and have not yet
released a product and so the reason for
that is we built our company a lot more
like a biotech company so our lead
product is a treatment for in attention
specifically attention and cognitive
deficits in ADHD patients and we've had
now four trials culminating in a large
nationwide 350 subject first of its kind
pivotal trial that we're using as a full
package
to bring to FDA for a prescribed double
treatment for ADHD and then we have a
whole portfolio of products based on
that core technology and a number of
other technologies across neurology and
mental health that we hope in the next
you know two to five years there's
patients that are playing their medicine
is one of the phrases we like to say I'm
happy to talk about anything else but
that's us you know and it's fascinating
it ridges the analogy of operating like
a biotech company I mean it raises
really some some fascinating questions
around well what is the active
ingredient how do you understand that
active ingredient but but you know we'll
come back to this but but the the other
fascinating point is that you know you
you defined it as a game you know this
is the gamification of behavioral
therapy but to really understand how
that works you have to understand how
the how the brain works yes and so the
Scientific founder of Akili is is Adam
Cazale who has a large neurobehavioral
lab in it Stanford UCSF sorry I get all
those california places but but looking
very specifically at brain changes that
are happening through sort of repetitive
study which is these these repetitive
activities all right
let's shift over and John could you tell
us a little bit more about what you're
doing and and kind of your your your
vision for the future on some of the
things you're working on yeah sure
thanks Greg so I'm part of J&J and JJ's
the largest healthcare company in the
world and it basically has a mission to
change the trajectory of human health
pretty modest mission statement but
that's our objective we have three
opcodes ones consumer ones met device
the other ones Pharmaceuticals I'm in
the pharma division and and may not be
working here
how's this that's better there we go
Thanks so we're I'm in the pharma
division within J&J and what we're
trying to do visa vie at least digital
is really in two realms one is around
therapeutics which is sort of treating
known disease and there's this other
effort internally that we're trying to
sort of understand in its titled world
without disease so it's more it's more
aspirational than just prevention it's
really where we believe that that you
can actually get it in front of the
actual problem more so then then through
identifying known diseases but actually
even preventing the unknown diseases so
as it relates to digital on the
therapeutic side what we're trying to do
and this was part of the Apple J&J
collaboration was saw the need to change
the way that we bring products to market
so as you know products are incredibly
expensive to to get approved we they
take a long time we wanted to shorten
and cheapen that process there's a lot
of reasons in terms of price pressure
and also just that the competition is is
getting faster the other part relates to
understanding how digital is going to
affect the marketplace so we operate in
a market what is digital gonna do to the
marketplace and so one of the things
that we wanted to understand was if we
deployed digital in a real-world type
setting how is that gonna change the
patient journey and the patient
experience so we did the study before
was called M stops it was in conjunction
with Scripps and the NIH and Aetna and
what we did was we patched people with
this ECG patch to see if they had atrial
fibrillation and the so what if it was
that yeah we detected more afib that's
fine but we actually changed the patient
journey where there was a four-fold
reduction in people who went to the ER
and there was a significant increase in
the people who went to cardiologist
office at the first point of contact and
entry into the health system so you're
changing the value you're changing the
patient journey which means that you
actually
changing the value chain and we needed
to understand what that looked like and
so as part of been part of my pitch
internally to to get them to buy it's a
sign off on the Apple change in
collaboration was we need to understand
what that new value chain looks like if
we're going to be successful in the new
world so I'll just leave it at that in
terms of the high level sort of points
of view and ways that we're trying to
understand how digital is going to
affect how we operate well in if you
didn't hear that at the very beginning
John said that their goal is to change
healthcare which you know you would
think might be a little bit ambitious
but then when you realize that he he
represents the largest healthcare
company in the world and they've created
a partnership with the most I don't know
if it still is the most valuable company
in the world Apple and how you got the
the two of them to sit down and shake
hands over this you know I suppose is
another longer discussion maybe an
entire symposium on itself about itself
and you know in answer to the question
is it working
anybody who's tried to run a clinical
trial knows how difficult it is to get
patient enrollment the average rate of
enrollment is about half a patient per
site per month which means that many
sites don't enroll any patients you'll
get a few patients over over the course
of year whereas the Apple Heart Study
enrolled over 400,000 patients in
something like eight eight months so
really it's a success on an order of
magnitude that that our clinical
development industry can only dream
about so so I think the ambitions are
well prepped placed and and and the
expectations are accurate well so now
speaking of of someone who's has
experience navigating a partnership
between a small company and a large
company
well it's good let me let me give you
the
give you the mic and the reason I
mentioned that is that Proteus has had a
successful partnership with Asuka so one
of the youngest companies in the world
with one of the oldest companies in the
world and you know we would love to hear
a little bit about that too as well as a
little bit more about Proteus sure this
one working ok great
yeah honored to be here I feel like I
don't deserve to be this this table
actually says pretty looks pretty
awesome I've got a produce about two and
a half years parties has been around
actually since 2001 and we're digital
medicines company and we make medicines
Digital and we actually were founded on
sort of the principle of identifying
three gaps that were perceived in
healthcare and how they might be
answered with sort of a single or simple
question
the gaps being that medicines aren't
working in the real world like we might
anticipate or hope they were see that
they work in clinical trials that
patients aren't taking their medicines
as we wished or hope that they might
knowing from decades of literature
reviews and real-world studies that
about 50% of people take their medicines
as prescribed of course varying somewhat
but not dramatically by disease State or
acuity and and that medications are
becoming increasingly more expensive and
less affordable in an era where we're
trying to pay for value and the simple
question then being did my patient take
their medicine and when and actually a
fundamentally belief that if 50 percent
of people aren't taking their medicines
then we can't be blaming the patient in
any other industry other than health
care when 50 percent of the end users
are failing or struggling to achieve the
end goal we would never blame the end
user we'd fix the product and that was
sort of fundamentally at the core of
what we thought we'd do together as a
company and as many companies that
coming together because now as a device
company as well as a pharmaceutical
company and and then software and and
healthcare delivery we've brought
together a lot of industries to develop
medicines that talk to your smartphone
and we've done this through a very tiny
ingestible sensor it's the size of it
and in fact we we put them here in our
business card and it's literally made of
dietary minerals copper of magnesium and
a little bit of silicon in very very
trace quantities and it's powered by the
body it's it's turned on when it's
swallowed and then it passes right
through you
and during that brief time it's enabled
to transmit data about the medication
what medication was what time it was
taken to the individual pill and end
dose paired with with wearable
technology that as an a band-aid form
factor that patients are you know able
to measure their step count their arrest
activity level and heart rate and other
metrics these together then create a
data set that enables really
observational care in the ambulatory
setting as physicians we're both artists
and scientists and in our efforts to be
scientists we rely on observation and
yet vast majority of care in this world
is delivered outside of observation in
the ambulatory world where we actually
don't know how our patients are behaving
or performing and most patients actually
want to be known by their provider they
don't go to the physician to withhold
information typically and we that's one
of the things that I've been overwhelmed
with that Proteus is is how willing
patients are to share this data within
the confines of a HIPAA compliant and
secure system that of course is at table
stakes for us but and I'll finish by
just saying what's what's fascinating is
once we know exactly what medicine is
being taken and went to the to the
minute if we needed to know that not
only do we now enable a clinical trial
or a CRO workplace and real-world
evidence phase for evidence environment
in every patient
potentially but we also enable
value-based arrangements and we have
actually a value-based contract in place
today that as soon as you know when a
med is being taken and that it's being
taken on label we can now start to price
medications based on their outcome and
we have I could talk more about this as
well but this gets us to then our our
Otsuka relationship which I again I
think I'll say for maybe our next phase
of discussion but it's an awesome
opportunity for us to now take
challenging mental health medications
that where as we pointed out one of the
biggest challenges as they have side
effects they're often not taken well and
they they often don't work like we want
them to how do we then put in outcomes
arrangement in place to at least price
them to the outcome we want to achieve
terrific terrific the you know III
mentioned it the beginning it's the the
evidence being let's build on evidence
and and let's move with that and and the
evidence generated by by Proteus is is
really not just positive but it's
surprising how how knowing how difficult
it is to to affect adherence and then
and then seeing that you can take
patients who've been labeled as
medically refractory now behaviorally
reflective of medically refractory and
actually demonstrate a positive outcome
based based on on medication adherence
but I want to dive a little bit deeper
into this idea of generating evidence in
a more traditional sense and Eddie I'm
gonna I'm gonna jump back to you you're
running a pivotal clinical trial an
fda-approved clinical trial he tell us a
little bit more about that particularly
around what endpoints had to be
developed for this and and how that
interaction with the the you know the
usual suspects the FDA the P I is the
principal investigators around the
development of novel endpoints sure sure
just a little bit of innovation when
you're trying to put a video game into a
trial so we had we had a lot of fun with
that
we I think starting at sort of a basic
level we brought forward a thesis to
build this company that if we were gonna
do so we couldn't just say clinical
trials are too hard and actually that's
just a story in people's heads right
clinical trials are either always hard
are always easy but they're always
something it doesn't really matter the
thing that you're putting in it just
means you have to innovate a little bit
or or come up with some creative ideas
so there are you know our trial that
Gregg's mentioning is 20 sites over 350
children nationwide I mean it's at the
same scale and scope of pivotal trials
for drugs and mental health and
specifically an ADHD
we used about 2/3 of our sites are the
sort of same top recruiting sites for
all the ADHD registration trials so they
know how to run those trials lots of
innovation here one there's logistics
around getting you know a tablet or a
smartphone into someone's hands there's
logistics in terms of the data so one
thing that's really interesting scooter
is talking about when you ingest a pill
that has a sensor you get data on our
treatment which is used on a on a an
iPad or similar device you also get
real-time data in terms of use
compliance and even progress we didn't
want to ignore that so we had to build
in some protocols so that staff at
centers who are not used to looking at
any data until the end of the study
can somehow look at the data without
being influenced because we think it's
important to the treatment and we have
blinding and control issues so what
you've seen a lot in in digital health
well I guess the first thing you've seen
a lot is by and large there are not
large prospective trials run most people
are not doing so and if they are they're
not well controlled we said we want to
set the highest possible bar and so we
we built a control which was actually an
educational video game with all the same
reward timing loops as as our treatment
and then we even went further and
blinded the participants and the
clinicians in such a way that we were
testing to potentially effective
interventions so actually even a
different blinding hypothesis so for us
clinical trial wonks that's super
exciting for the rest of us we like what
in the world this is this is really not
fodder for a panel I like it so what we
ended up doing was implementing all
these systems to properly blind everyone
but and and that was very innovative we
have but it but it can be done I guess
that's that's kind of the point and so
we sat with FDA a couple years ago we
had multiple meetings with FDA where we
proposed we went back and forth and we
actually worked with them they've been
incredible to work with to date and and
I think very collaborative and
you know people were telling us don't go
to FDA because they're gonna change your
paradigm and we said no we want we want
to work with FDA and it was great it was
actually great we designed a really
great trial together so that's kind of
on the on the design side in terms of
outcome measure that I think it's really
important I mean we what I'm gonna say
is going to sound like it's coming out
of two sides of our mouths so one more
general philosophy I don't think we
should be trying to bring things in to
clinical trials at this stage that are
different or disparate from accepted
known clinical endpoints I think we want
to be showing that this actually works
at the same time sometimes digital
treatments can target things differently
so in our case we're targeting cognition
it turns out there are no approved
treatments on the drug or device side
that directly target cognitive function
so we necessarily had to not invent
outcome measures but use outcome
measures that maybe aren't the most
accepted standard as primary so what we
did is we took standard outcome measures
that are used for kind of looking at the
totality of the disorder we put them as
secondary endpoints we measure them in
the exact same way as drug trials and as
a primary outcome measure we looked at
something that's accepted and known as a
measure of cognitive function so what
what I don't think should be done is
changing the accepted and known part you
can innovate you can only innovate so
many things and I generally don't
recommend innovating an outcome measure
for a pivotal trial I absolutely
recommend using digital to get better
and better outcome measures over time
but those of course have to be validated
so that was a little bit of a rambling I
don't know if that answered the question
no no it's fascinating and well and it's
interesting the hurdles that that you
face doing
it's a novel intervention but it's a
standard clinical trial design you know
where's John you know you're you're
we're talking about you know it's called
various things mobile clinical trials
decentralized clinical trials virtual
clinical trials but it promises to be
better faster cheaper you know reaching
a broader audience my question is what
are the what are the hurdles I mean it
sounds so good why isn't everybody doing
this you know what what and you know
what why are you first in line I don't
know why actually um they probably
should I think it's around I think
there's a lot of inertia that companies
to do this there's a lot of fear and as
I found a lot of internal dynamics
that's or to prevent innovation I think
that's sort of what innovation is as
getting over the fear getting over the
inertia it's almost the counter
definition of it but I think certainly
the technology is enabled there's sort
of also a sort of market awareness now
that this can be done I think that
people have seen examples where you have
you know maybe 500 patient studies a
sample size of 500 and it can sort of be
encapsulated within a few sites and
that's it and so those can largely be
done virtually when what because in the
cardiovascular space we tend to run
15,000 20,000 27,000 patient studies we
thought we would need to do is we need
to scale it in a way that sort of
broadens the patient profiles so one of
the criticisms of our CTS is that it's
highly selected populations because of
course you might get the treatment
effect size etc etc all good all
reasonable given sort of where we are
but we wanted to sort of address that
and say what is the therapeutic actually
look like or what is the diagnostic in
this case for the Apple launch what does
it actually look like in the real word
with a very broad population so that you
really can get a sense of what it's
going to do in the real world but yet
using an RCT type design to sort of
bring people in so the the if that's
your goal then going broad and wide sort
of forces you to become more
decentralized and using virtual channels
and you know now people are
carrying these phones everywhere by the
time baby boomers are sort of well the
current sort of generation becomes baby
boomers current generation meaning those
in those 40s and 50s become baby boomers
I mean there's going to be incredible
penetration of that kind of technology
so we wanted to be out of the curve see
what that looked like the I think the
challenges are probably more internal I
think the FDA is very willing to daddy's
point they're really really excited they
used to I think they have a bad rap they
they used to be really sort of not
cooperative they've changed quite a bit
in many ways so that combined with the
penetration technology combined with
sort of like market needs combined with
you know just just a recognition that
Fang those companies are just so
valuable that they've got to have
something that maybe life sciences she
looked to was sort of a recognition that
we should probably go this way and
leverage the abilities that they sort of
give us just follow on I mean from a
different perspective
we're slightly smaller than J&J it turns
out so one of the reasons we so we
actually also run pilot remote trials
and I'm a huge supporter of for all the
reasons John said a 100% agree I think
sometimes companies want to jump to that
right without any I won't even call it
ground truth I actually believe that the
remote measurement and remote validation
is the ground truth because that's what
happens in the real world but going
directly to that sort of without any
type of correlation or without any type
of at least knowledge of what happens in
a sort of standard more standard bricks
and mortar study where we do have
reference data on you know in cardiology
I think that's an important thing for
small companies too is to you know if
you're if you're gonna innovate on areas
show that okay we're innovating maybe
it's better maybe it's worse maybe it's
comparable they're different but we at
least have datasets from a couple
different sources including the standard
I personally I think that's a way to go
it's also as a company looking for you
know kind of acceptance and adoption in
a medical world which is becoming more
and more fragmented having multiple
lines of credibility is is critical as
well and so I think you know
and others would support you know it's
not it's not about maybe it's about in a
Fiat timeframe throwing out the standard
trials which I might be supportive of
because there's so many flaws but really
today it's about showing those can be as
good or better in many different ways
but not immediately jumping to that and
kind of closing our eyes and ears on
what happens on standard trials as well
so any at some point
Akili had the choice of are we gonna are
we going to go the FDA route or the non
FDA route maybe give us a little bit of
a highlight how that decision was made
pretty easy decision so which sounds
like the opposite usually the pretty
easy decision is put something out on
the consumer market and see what happens
with you know low dollars for us we we
care deeply about making sure that if
we're gonna build a business it has to
be a real treatment that dramatically
helps people and if we're gonna build a
real treatment that dramatically helps
people we better make sure it gets to
the people who need it and we were a bit
concerned in the general dominated
healthcare world of software especially
in our field where we're talking about
the brain this tends to be one of the
highest preyed upon areas in crappy
software you can all pull up your app
stores right now in search brain or ADHD
or depression or anxiety we felt that it
was really important for doctors
essentially to have the ability to be
part of this process by being able to
prescribe it and understand the data
flow and the FDA approval for patients
to actually understand that this is
legitimate because your average patient
on the street where who I have a ton of
respect for your average parent of a
child with ADHD is not able to or has
the time or whatever to scrutinize all
these things that are on the App Store
so from our perspective what we've seen
is that people who really need help and
here we're removing the kind of stigma
issue because that's that is actually a
very separate issue in terms of access
people who really need help many times
it's not by sort of scouring you know
the internet and consumer it's by
showing up at a doctor's office and
having both the doctor and the patient
come to
in agreement that this is a really good
valid solution so that's really what
drove it for us it's not to say that
there aren't innovative come consumer
models that can get to that same level
of credibility and acceptance but we
felt it was actually an easy trade-off
with the understanding that it would
take a lot more money a lot more time
and a lot more risk but we're willing to
undertake that you know very interesting
I'd like to shift back to a tool in kind
of building on this discussion of
bringing treatments that work to people
yet talk space didn't necessarily have
to do clinical trials however I'm sure
there were adoption barriers hurdles to
get through in the past and continually
and and that will go forward and before
before I let you answer just invite
people if you have questions please
start approaching the mics and and as
soon as you know we have questions from
the audience we'll turn to them until
then we'll just you know keep the
discussion going
but anyway so it's go back to you and
tell us a little bit about the the
adoption hurdles that you faced and what
you see going forward sure so I would
say the topic of clinical studies in
adoption hurdles actually go
hand-in-hand so in the behavioral health
space there's a number of different
stakeholders there's certainly the
patient there's the providers and
there's the health systems and so first
and foremost we had an alternative way
of delivering care that raised a lot of
eyebrows how can you text message your
therapists and really call it therapy
and that's where having clinical studies
that actually demonstrated the efficacy
of the product were really worth their
weight in gold and so we had partnered
with some universities in terms of being
able to track outcomes and so again
being able to demonstrate the clinical
impact as well as also reminding folks
that there was very little clinical
evidence in a traditional face-to-face
setting and so we suddenly started
opening eyes that we have evidence it's
really good and you probably don't have
evidence
elsewhere kind of ring a few bells I
think the other approach specifically
with talk space and thinking about those
different stakeholders is that our
mission was never to eradicate the
traditional care models we fully
recognized and appreciated that those
were appropriate for some people maybe
for many people but we also recognized
as I said that there is a huge piece of
the population that wasn't able to
access care and so our our goal was
targeting those people who couldn't
access care for a variety of different
reasons and so you know it from the
consumer side it's a self selection
approach right they're either going to
adopt to a digital approach in
behavioral health or they realize it's
not for them and that's okay I would say
the same is true on the provider side we
have some folks who recognize the value
the efficiency as well as the clinical
quality that they can deliver on the
platform because of the tools that we
provide to our therapists on the
platform but for some it just does not
feel like the right approach and
traditional face to face is where they
want to stay interestingly and I say
interestingly from having lived in the
payer side of the world for several many
years of my career and they are
typically seen as more of the ones that
put up barriers the payers were actually
one of our fastest adopters when we
entered the enterprise space now granted
we had a lot of validity from being in
the consumer markets but the payer world
they are hearing every single day from
their major customers which are the big
employers that our employees cannot
access behavioral care you don't have
enough providers you don't have
providers in the right place and it's a
pretty finite pie when you talk to
health plans about trying to grow their
network and so the a digital solution
like this comes along in it again
becomes almost a bit of a non grater I'm
not going to say anything is easy but it
was easier than I thought it would be
which again underscores that this
chin has validity and it wasn't meant to
be an eradication of another way of
accessing care but really a supplement
and opening up different channels to
care one of the things that still
fascinates me when I hear people when I
hear you talk to people in your company
talking to people there's there's
typically invariably there'll be a
physician who says hmm yeah yeah I guess
that's okay I guess I guess I could use
that when when you look at the numbers
depending on what you include in
behavioral health and mental health it's
somewhere between 15 million and a
hundred million people affected in the
United States and there's some somewhere
between ten thousand maybe thirty
thousand behavioral health workers so
the question of access is just amazingly
uneven here and so I guess maybe the you
know to make my comment in the form of a
question are you do you feel like you're
opening sort of new channels is it to
different patients incremental patients
you know are in business terms
incremental markets or is it still the
same sort of provider based yeah so with
the providers I would say it's we've
really attracted a talent pool of folks
who recognize that the flexibility that
the platform allows for them and not
having to be in a set place at a set
time and having no-shows and scheduling
appointments has really opened up I
would say provider recruiting has also
been one of the easier hurdles we've
crossed again not not thinking that that
would necessarily be the case we write
again they are able to see more patients
more efficiently and get paid from it do
it from their couch or wherever they may
be
again there are still providers who
can't adopt to the digital framework and
maybe okay we do again go back to our
clinical outcomes and our clinical
studies where we can show symptom
reduction as fast as or as good as face
to face often better but we don't put
ourselves out as we are better we put
ourselves out as an option in terms of
the user base what we have found is that
about 60 to 70 percent of people who
come on to talk space and use the
platform have not been able to access
therapy elsewhere so it really
demonstrates opening up the doors and
getting more people into care that can
be very beneficial not only for their
emotional well-being but of course for
their total medical cost and well-being
we also track for people who have been
in therapy before
do you prefer doing talk space or do you
prefer face-to-face now there may be
somewhat bias because they're using talk
space but it was about 90 percent or so
who said the convenience far outweighs
face-to-face I can message seven days a
week I'm not having to wait for a
scheduled appointment and I was actually
able to develop a really strong bond
with my therapist which is something
that we know is very critical to a
successful outcome in therapy and as I
mentioned early on about the way that
people pick therapists and a traditional
face-to-face setting it's very random
and here we've been able to put some
science and some algorithms around our
therapists and who do we think they will
best fit in terms of our user base I
mean so many wonderful surprises you
know develop a stronger bond with your
therapists in in the digital space so we
have a question hi I have a question
from patient consumer perspective so
it's also an access question but who is
going to pay for these new therapeutics
as well as things like adherence in a
lot of cases is because people can't
afford their medicine you know from a
patient support perspective so don't
show me the money yeah I can start with
then there's there's several models
that that have been used but as I
mentioned we're we have value-based
contracts in the marketplace today so
one of those I can talk about it it's
public and we have a press release on
abacus but this was with a capitated
provider group and desert desert oasis
and in Palm Springs
they have about 80 thousand senior lives
the average age in our study with them
right now is 72 we've had really rapid
enrollment almost 150 patients just in
the last several weeks and it but the
beauty of it is that they are paying us
and our fees and services only when
patients are 80 percent adherent and
only then we get a bonus payment when
they come under control
so it's an interesting way for them of
course they every bed day is an adverse
event and they're a capitated group that
subsists on managing care and managing
the sciences and so I think starting
with pave eiders of which there are now
many in our in our country employers
actually are also an interesting I think
route into the payer marketplace but
starting with it especially pave adders
where they care very much about the
outcomes both financial and clinical is
a great way to prove it when you can put
your money I think kind of where your
mouth is on outcomes other comments
about pair models yeah I think I think
you're gonna see a lot of bear models
develop especially if we think about
digital therapeutics broadly there's a
lot of sort of different types emerging
today you've even in this sort of
nascent industry that we're in and you
can look up the digital therapeutic
alliance if you want which is kind of
the first industry group that really is
consolidate and advocating and educating
on this front so you can see the types
of companies involved there's already a
few different types of pay models
evolving right there you have different
sort of value-based pricing models you
have potentially drug pricing models and
DC codes even though these things are
pieces of software in many cases you
have medical device or rather medical
benefits and even DME s that you're
seeing start to emerge and I think it
really goes to the philosophy that if
you are injecting a just a new treatment
modality for patients
doctors that care for patients just like
anything else there are going to be
different plug-and-play ways that those
are used and the one we haven't
mentioned is there will still be some
consumer pay models where consumers are
you know you can either say on the
negative side bearing the burden or on
the positive side exerting choice to to
pay so I think all of the above actually
exists in a way and that's one of my
favorite things thinking about the
emergence of this new type of industry
here using technology there is a single
way and one of the earlier panels talked
about it the black box way by which
pills today are covered and it has
evolved into a very inefficient and
negative system I think we're at this
precipice where there's a lot of
potential ways that this could go and I
think it would be best for the industry
to keep all of them open I'd love to see
a company doing every one of those ways
I mentioned to keep all of those
optionality xopen and keep it more kind
of flexible for patients I mean
innovation doesn't stop in the
laboratory it doesn't stop when you get
the product approved it continues in you
know monied x' me to wonder are you are
you approaching this with a different
mindset knowing that you have to be
different and create more innovative
pricing models because it's not a pill
it's not a standard to kind of continue
that cycle of innovation to increase
adoption and and and use the products
yeah we certainly are I mean we're we're
building to the point as we approach
launch that is that actually enables
multiple of those options and so the
point being we're not going to be
deterministic or paternalistic which are
two very big problems in today's
medicine world I believe we're gonna
build optionality that takes a little
bit more work but I think it's really
really important to enable access as
quickly as possible and flexible access
is going to be a good thing for this
not about another question yes thank you
this is a question for Lin then what's
it going to take for Medicaid and
Medicare to cover service or product
like yours both at your end was it going
to take and where if one were to not the
government where would you start so I I
think I heard your question correctly
which was around where does Medicare
Medicaid fit in the space and the
government's impact is that right yes
and what's like what's it going to take
to move to move the ball yes I wish I
knew that magical answer in terms of
what it's going to take to move them we
do see progress coming along in general
with the telehealth laws what's been I
think a little bit interesting is that
the federal government from a VA
perspective is a little bit ahead of
where the other agencies are Medicaid
for me as a very interesting market I
think it's one that we could have a very
immediate and tangible impact in but yet
we are currently held up by the laws for
example in New York State where we've
really spent some time looking at what
those what the legislation looks like
and we're waiting for it to be enacted
so that we can actually bring this out
to their Medicaid population and of
course Medicaid is a state-by-state
endeavor Medicare also I think moving in
the right direction in terms of allowing
alternate forms of treatment and being a
little bit less restrictive obviously
pretty restrictive beforehand in terms
of it had to be in a certain geography
where there wasn't enough access to care
and you had to meet certain standards so
we hope to see all of that loosening up
in the spirit of opening up access to
care for both of those popular
Shen's follow-up to discutir or wonder
if other speakers have a yeah well you
know I think it's been a strong
there has been a strong signal as
recently as January of this year with
the rpm remote patient monitoring codes
for instance so CMS took a took a stand
which is I think a very positive one and
you know there's been some pushback I
think by the industry that oh you know
but co-pays are still required and it
you know they didn't go far enough but I
think it was a definitive stance
actually in favor of remote patient
monitoring technologies that can now be
reimbursed for in a fee-for-service
environment and then more even more
recently with a press release by CMS
that these could not be used in a
Medicare Advantage context and so I
think it's these are strong strong
signals for us and we know the
value-based movement seems to be at
least in the current administration a
strong priority and so you know
mirroring those two I think is is moving
us all in the right direction and then
you know taking advantage of CMMI is
always a great opportunity I think
they're they have in some cases more
money than they can play with actually
that it is in perpetuity the CMMI grant
that that was brought in through the ACA
is is money that I don't know in any
partisan environment will go away given
the way that it's been funded and so
that that's an opportunity I think will
continue to last for people to develop
novel pay you know payment models has
anyone aware of any Lobby working on
this at all any names any lobbyists so
actually although although I don't think
they'd call themselves a lobbying group
there are similarly we see we see
innovation happening kind of at the
social level almost in the adoption of
these digital therapeutics so there is
the digital therapeutic alliance and the
executive director is here today
there's a new organization called the
digital medicine Society which is going
to be announced in the next couple of
months so there you
to use that phrase it takes a village I
mean it takes this has to be a
multidisciplinary approach that brings
policymakers along with clinicians along
with innovators together in order to
push some of these forward and and it's
it's also equally fascinating to see at
that trade group level advocacy group
level those those people are coming
together as well yeah one of the
specific examples along with the DTA is
a group called advil med which works in
the medical device space and they've
sort of started to to work on this
concept but with an eye toward the
future of medical device innovation
which includes digital technologies of
course so that's an area that I think
you're seeing a lot of work in that
hopefully will lead to something but I
think it's a it's almost like a a
groundswell effort like at some point
these the little holes in the in the
levy eventually lead to something very
big and it's hard to predict exactly
which initiative is going to punch
through first but I totally agree with
scooter I mean I think some of the some
of what you're seeing in different
niches of healthcare industry are really
promising and I think we'll get there
but those are some of the groups that
are that are working on it right now
thank you so in order to get these
things done you know we talked about
changing healthcare you know you know in
many different ways the incredibly
promising but we sort of building on
this idea that that we need
organizations we need to bring you know
multiple parties together and each one
of you has as either partnered or
interacted with work with large
organization and you know let's keep
this on the positive side because we
know how difficult it is but there's
something about what your value
propositions have been that got their
attention and and you know scooter maybe
I'll bring it back let's start with you
again you know
proteus at cyka not exactly who you
would have thought would be kind of the
ideal you know that the expected
combination yet somehow you
hold it off it's it's it's been a
terrific relationship and it's
fascinating you know you mentioned it's
a company it's a company with 100-year
business plans meeting a company with
you know three to three months nine
months funding cycles and it's been it's
been a terrific opportunity for us to
actually to both innovate quickly but
leverage each other's strengths and so
you know for instance we have our own
manufacturing facility in Hayward
California where we're making these
these essentially very very tiny
integrated circuits in a semiconductor
technology it enables us to go very fast
and very cheap at scale but that meets a
roll-to-roll pharmaceutical
manufacturing process that actually
became really seamlessly integrated from
a manufacturing perspective but then at
the same time from a commercial
distribution perspective we didn't
didn't begin to have a workforce that
could have enabled distribution or
education in the marketplace and
leveraging then their assets with ours
has been a terrific opportunity and then
you know there's all the sort of fun
intricacies of working you know across
great distances and languages that have
actually turned into there's some really
great stories I couldn't go into but
even just errors in translation that
have turned into innovative
opportunities and you know that there's
been a lot of really fun things that I
think working with companies of
different sizes that you know we butt
heads all the time but in at the same
moment we're having a great operational
success and they've been a terrific
partner so so tell us what do you put in
a hundred year business plan they're
they're broad visions for sure but it's
it's you know it's they're very
committed to to mental health and and
have been and I think you're making an
even stronger stance internally and have
many more drugs with us that are already
planned in and in the process so I think
for them it's it's more about where do
we where do we move a population of
patients to in an environment that we
cannot anticipate I think you know
coming off of Walters talk I don't even
know what the future is anymore
you know it's interesting John how did
you get these giants to shake hands
not easily the I think of trying to
approach it more from a fact-based point
of view is just like okay guys look at
what's going on in the market
you've got digital making a penetration
and you can't stop it
like there's no way that you're gonna
sort of hold that back pricing is an
issue so you've got to bring down the
cost by which you develop your products
and you need to increase your cycle time
because you know it takes what five
seven years and then you got a patent
life of whatever and it's like that
doesn't work in today's world so much
because for example in the digital area
I don't know what it's like for you or
for you but or for you but for us it's
you know it's it's too long really
whereas in the digital area from what I
can see it can be as short as eighteen
months that you can get every one dot
release we can get some changes so I
said if we're gonna sort of be where the
puck we think is going to be and I sort
of painted that picture I said okay that
was internally there and then really
Apple had their own vision it wasn't
aligned with ours initially but sort of
brought them to sort of because they're
new to healthcare they don't really know
the dynamics we can hire people in but
unless you have sort of the DNA of
operating in the healthcare environment
you don't really know the issues are
going to face in implementation so I had
to sort of walk them off their their
story line to sort of get us in line
together and and that was sort of I
think the nut of it and persistence
probably more than anything else just
there were so many times when this thing
was gonna go dead I know but you just
pick it back up and you try again so I
would just recommend that that for
innovation I think that's always a key
part
yes we so we've done a couple
partnerships we've done an R&D
partnership with Pfizer and Alzheimer's
which was exciting from a monitoring
perspective we just announced that we
did a really innovative partnership with
company not as well known here in the US
but called shionogi so it's a big
pharmaceutical company in Japan that
similarly has hundred-year business
plans and and some other things and
extremely innovative partnership where
we're sort of Co owning the commercial
model so we're building the entire
commercial hub system that supports our
products and shionogi is building up the
sort of Salesforce and medical affairs
to be able to launch products in Japan I
think there it's I think this is not
just truth Digital here anyone who's
been in business development is true
deals always almost fall apart a hundred
times right as john was just saying and
I think when they don't fall apart it's
because there's some shared vision that
is too powerful to let it and sometimes
they still fall apart but that's the
thing that pulls it through so in this
case you know in both of our instances
working with larger companies you know
we kind of kept the drumbeat of we are
doing this no matter what sometimes
small companies you know kind of feel
like they're in a subjugated position to
a big company but I think if you believe
in your vision enough and say we're
gonna do this and this is much better
for everyone and including patients if
we do this together
it sounds really kind of hand-holding
and and silly and cliche but it's not
it's powerful and that's the type of
thing that's why most people in health
care come to work every day right is to
help people so I think keeping that
vision is the thing that got us through
a lot of these deals and then then you
start to think creatively you start to
think all right what's our end goal here
is to get it to the patient to either of
us big or small know how to get that
done exactly today no we don't let's be
honest and then you start to get into a
little bit more of a problem-solving
framework which is how we've how we've
approached our partnerships so so Lynn
how did you get those contracts I mean
it was it the kumbayas and the handhold
or was it just hey we're gonna save you
money yeah it was actually a little less
about money I think there was a couple
things that impacted first you mentioned
in the very beginning and your opening
remarks about a consumer business or an
enterprise business and I would say the
benefit that we had is being in the
consumer business first gave us first
the data to demonstrate the outcomes
which were very powerful but also
demonstrated that an individual consumer
was willing to pay out of pocket to
access care and that's how big the
barriers to accessing care are and so we
were able to rely a little bit on the
fact of our very large consumer base
rely on our clinical data and
demonstrating the outcomes and so it
becomes a much easier conversation when
some of those things line up and you
know as you mentioned some companies go
enterprise some go consumer I think we
played it the right way if we had gone
direct Enterprise without any consumer
experience I'm sure that we would not
have been as successful as we were here
so it just kind of has worked out again
it there is a true need in the
healthcare system as well and I think
that's very important it's not that
we're bringing something out that isn't
a true end user need people need access
to care they struggle with it and so
we're helping solve those problems and
being able to demonstrate that was
really critical
great great all right final lightning
round
I'm going to ask for one word from each
of you that summarizes what you're doing
and your hope we've heard a lot of words
and buzz words and phrases today you
know data empowerment efficiency
responsibility let's end on one word who
goes first clinical quality
- ate it it's okay then I'm going
forward my word was gonna be chaos I
think we need to embrace that this is a
chaotic space and that the world is a
bit chaotic but I would say chaos with a
purpose if I can use a couple words I
think the word is value healthcare is
just basically two expense in the US and
we wanted to solve for that I'm gonna
steal your word empowerment actually I
think it's about empowering patients and
providers perfect all right well my word
is thank you
[Applause]